what makes the perfect cup of tea or
should it be
who makes the perfect cup of tea some
some people have just got the knack it
is a question that's been debated many
times but there is some new research
that suggests the answer may depend in
part at least on what kind of
water you're using now scientists at the
university of leeds
found that in areas with hard water the
mineral content prevented flavor
compounds
forming properly and so they say
adding milk before the water so you put
the milk in
then the tea bag and then the water is
the key to a tasty brew
surely that cannot be right let's talk
to eileen donahey afternoon tea expert
and qualified tea
champion from the ukt academy good to
see you this morning
putting a tea bag into me and thank you
very much for inviting me
um i can't wait to explain what makes
the best cup of tea
because i know that there are um a range
of different opinions
everyone has a different opinion on it
and i want to talk through
what makes the best cup of tea in my
opinion well go on then off you go how
do i get a decent brew
well first of all make sure that you
have the cattle boiled and there was a
big debate
on um if you should add the tea bag
first
or milk what i say is you should uh get
take your tea cup
put the tea bag in first then add the
water
let it brew for the recommended time on
the brand
and then take the tea bag out and then
add your milk
it's really important you do it that way
because you won't be able to see
the strength of the tea otherwise um if
you add the milk first
and if you add the milk first you could
be left with a very muggy cup of tea
if you add too much i was always told
growing up being a good northerner that
when you put the milk in it stops the
tea
brewing is that right
well really where this whole idea of
putting the milk in first comes from
when porcelain first came to the uk not
everyone could afford it so a cheaper
earthenware version was made
and that cheaper version couldn't
withstand the
heat of the hot tea so the tea cup would
crack
so what people would do first is they
would add the milk that would really act
as a seal in the teacup
and that would uh help so when the tea
was added um
it wouldn't crack so that's really where
it comes from in order for you to see
the quality of the tea and the strength
of the tea
you can't do that if the milk's in first
so i think
a tea second is better what's your
what's the
the best type of tea to be drinking
builders tea as we like to call it over
here or
something a bit more sophisticated like
a darjeeling
well there are a range of teas available
and
if you're going for afternoon tea maybe
you want to have something a bit more
um luxurious like a darjeeling and if
you did you
definitely wouldn't add milk if it's
more everyday there are
a whole host of different tea bags
available
personally i drink blue sleep tea a lot
at home and it's very easy to make
it's not messy as whole as some people
think um so a real mixture
i just want to see the look on your face
allen because my director this morning
jeremy are you
kiwi or or aussie jeremy i can't
remember aussie
he's an aussie and he says he makes a
cup of tea
tea bag in the cup cold water puts it in
the microwave
definitely definitely not
that would be a big no-no a microwave is
not needed to make tea
uh kettle is the main thing that you
need to make a lovely cup of tea
i definitely wouldn't be going near any
microwaves to make a cup of tea
absolutely not
i could not agree with you more um we
could do with you over here permanently
because
sometimes the cups of tea we get over
here a little bit lackluster
let me tell you uh but hopefully
everyone here in the studio
andrew is not fair he makes a decent
copper hopefully they're going to take
some notice so make decent tea from now
on alan good to talk to you thank you
thank you very much to you first
microwave microwave jeremy
so much trouble